hello and we're glad you've joined us
for this live
webinar when cell growth is critical
evaluating co2 incubator parameters
for cell therapy i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning and it's
brought to you by
thermo fisher scientific to learn more
about
our sponsor please visit them at
www.thermofisher.com
so let's get started you can pose your
questions to the speaker during the
presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop down
box located on the far
left of your screen labeled ask a
question
and click the send button questions will
be answered
after the presentation to enlarge the
slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience any technical problems
seeing or hearing this presentation
just click on the support tab found at
the top right
of the presentation window or report
your pro problem
by typing it into the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located in the top right of your
presentation window and follow the
process
of obtaining your credits i now present
today's speaker mary kay bates
the senior global cell culture scientist
at thermo fisher
scientific welcome mary kay you may now
begin
your presentation thanks susie
and hello everyone thank you for
attending and thank you to everyone at
lab roots for presenting this event
part of my job with thermo fisher is to
work with our
r d engineers to communicate what is
needed for cell and gene therapy
applications
to maximize ideal conditions for cell
growth in our cell culture incubators
as part of this work we have compared
different engineering approaches for the
control of the co2 incubator
especially looking at recovery following
a door opening
and we looked at recovery also
and we looked at uniformity and to be
honest we were surprised at the
variation that we found
so the basis of my presentation today is
to share some of these findings because
just comparing a list of functional
specifications
does not necessarily indicate how the
incubator performs
in practice also
incubators have been used in cell
culture since the 1950s
and i think that many of us have sort of
forgotten how each
parameter affects the cells themselves
and so we will also consider how
variation
in these separate incubator parameters
can affect cells
i'm excited to share this information
with you partly because
i wish i had understood this better for
applications and my own previous work
in cancer and gene therapy and also
because this information has been
helpful for some
cell therapy institutes directly so i
wanted to share it on a broader basis
in hopes you will find it helpful also
so let's get started i've set some goals
for
for today's presentation at the
conclusion of my talk
i hope that you will understand how each
parameter controlled by the co2
incubator affects cell growth
you will discover how incubator design
differences can affect the performance
of the incubator and thus
the health of your cells and finally i
hope that you will
learn that just like in reading a
journal article you should be able to
critically assess
equipment features based on the data
provided in brochures and technical
information from the manufacturer
so it's not just about comparing a list
of functional specifications
but you're also looking at practical
performance and you can ask for these
data
so that information should guide your
choice because ultimately
you have to perform iq oqpq testing as
you implement this equipment into your
processes
and you don't want any surprises
so as by way of introduction let's let's
kind of take a step back
and look at cells that we're culturing
so
as we've trended towards cell therapy
and gene therapy applications
we're seeing use of and growth of more
sensitive cells so
many of you are growing immortalized
cell lines like hek293 cells for example
just for production of cells or from
products from cells
but also many of you may be growing stem
cells for
direct use in human therapeutic
applications
certainly we're seeing a lot of
advancement and a lot of expansion
in looking at growth of immune cells
and finally human primary cells if you
think about
autologous cell therapy where you're
taking cells from the patient
modifying them and then putting them
back in the patient to treat
a condition in that patient
so the thing about cultured cells of
course is they're constantly
sampling the milieu around them that
that
in which they are so they're looking at
temperature humidity
atmosphere gas concentration nutrients
and stimulants and repressors in the
growth medium
companions are they alone in that cell
culture or are they
touching other related cells that may
trigger different gene expression or
differentiation and they're responding
to those conditions
and since the co2 incubator is there to
mimic
the in vivo conditions or you know the
conditions in the body from where the
cells originated
that means that each parameter affects
cell growth
and as we've just established cells
respond to changing conditions
so the take home there is that variation
in your incubation conditions
can cause variation in your process
results
because as your cells respond to
different conditions that can affect
gene expression or protein expression
and so on so now i want to take a look
at each of the
parameters in the provided by the
incubator individually
what are their effects on cells and what
happens when
we see variation in the incubator and
then compare different technologies for
achieving those
parameters so i think with an incubator
the first thing you think of is
temperature so
let's begin with temperature
so incubator temperature is there to
mimic the body temperature
so the reason we culture cells
especially human-derived cells at 37
degrees is because
that's body temperature and we know that
cells are extremely sensitive to
temperature and if you think about
part of your immune response is to
develop a fever
and you know that you don't feel very
well when your
temperature your body temperature is
above normal 37 degrees celsius
we also know that cells are generally
okay for a few days at refrigeration
the lower temperatures are generally
okay and this
is also physiological when you wake up
first thing in the morning before you've
had that first cup of coffee
your body temperature is often lower
than 37 degrees it might be 36.5 degrees
celsius
but higher temperatures are detrimental
to cells
in fact cells cannot withstand more than
a few hours of 2 degrees above normal
and of course this is in culture not
outside the body where
um you know a fever is also detrimental
but
maybe not as detrimental as uh itself
kind of naked in culture
so with that in mind let's look at how
recovery after a door opening of
temperature can vary
depending on the design of the incubator
so what i'm showing here is a table
showing recovery to 37 degrees or 98
percent
of 37 degrees after a 30 second door
opening so the inner and outer door of
the incubator was open for 30 seconds
and this is a common test for function
functional performance of an incubator
so left to right the small blue bar
shows recovery in five minutes
after a 30 second door opening and this
is an incubator with
a circulating fan and a temperature
probe located in the temp in the
incubator chamber
going left to right the yellow bar shows
a recovery
from a 30 second door opening to 37
degrees celsius
in an incubator without a circulating
fan
and you can see that recovery is a
little bit slower
if you put the temperature sensor in
what's called a bypass
location and i'm going to talk about
bypass sensors
later in the talk but essentially it's
outside the incubator
chamber that slows the recovery
even further so that's more than 10
minutes to recover to 37 degrees after a
30 second door opening
and then the last bar shows you more
than a 30 minute recovery time
for an incubator without a circulating
fan and with a bypass
temperature probe
so my point here is that even though
incubators
generally look very similar from the
outside
different technologies so different
design and engineering that goes into
those incubators can produce very
different
conditions for cells
the other thing that you might see in a
in a brochure for example
is um that in trying to
hurry or speed the recovery after a door
opening of temperature
you can see an overshoot of the desired
temperature so
here's a recovery graph from one
incubator on the left that shows
a speedy recovery to about 36 degrees
and then it slows as it approaches 37
degrees
and then if you focus on the graph for
incubator b
you can see it's actually a slower
recovery and then when it hits 37
degrees it keeps going so it
overshoots 37 degrees
and as we've just established higher
temperatures are actually more
detrimental for cells
so overshooting that set point of 37
degrees does not produce faster recovery
and it can be detrimental to cells
so i wanted to provide some tips to
maintain temperature
in your current incubator so i assume
that not everybody on the call today is
going to run out and buy new incubators
based on my talk but what can you do in
your current
incubator to maintain temperature better
for better growth of yourself
so number one and you're going to hear
this again limit
the number of times that you open the
incubator door
and limit the duration of
the door opening so for example if you
go to the incubator
and you pull out a stack of cells and
you carry them over to
the work surface and then you go back
and close the incubator door
that's not ideal so is there a place
next to the incubator
where you can put the cells and then
quickly close the incubator door to
better maintain that temperature
another tip is to pre-heat the growth
media and i hope that everyone is doing
this to pre-hit your growth media to
37 degrees partly because of course
putting
cold or room temperature growth media
will shock the cells
very bad for them but also preheating
that growth media helps better maintain
the temperature in the incubator
if you want to you can also preheat the
water that you provide
in the humidity reservoir that will also
help maintain the incubator temperature
because it won't have to work so hard
to heat up that cold water that you put
in
this is one we see especially in newer
buildings where
at night when no one is in the
laboratory the ambient temperature of
the laboratory
will change in order to save energy in
the heating and cooling system
so that affects how the incubator
functions especially in warmer climates
if the
if the laboratory heats up overnight
that can really
negatively affect how the incubator is
heating the cells inside
often even in clean rooms i walk in and
i see
building air ducts for heating and
cooling for the
for the room in the ceiling or on the
wall
and they're right pointed on the
incubator so
those of course blowing uh
intermittent cold or hot air on the
incubator again will
will change what the incubator is
experiencing and how it has to heat and
keep the cells so one thing to do
is you can use kind of a passive
air duct diverter to change
that airflow so that it's not blowing
directly on the incubator
i don't think this happens very often
but sometimes we all love to see
sunlight coming into our workspace so
make sure that that if you do have
windows such that sun
is shining on the incubator um use some
window blinds just to um keep that
sunlight from shining on the incubator
and then finally um if uh if overheating
is a concern for your incubator
an incubator with a backup temperature
probe
helps prevent overheating in the event
of a failure
of that primary temperature sensor
okay so that's temperature now i'm going
to look at the
second most important parameter provided
by the co2 incubator
and that is gas concentration so i'm
going to start with a little bit of
biology because i think
sometimes we think about the incubator
as just a place to put
the cells and then we can get on with
the next step in our day
and i think it's important to take a
step back and understand the biology
behind
all of these parameters and and how they
affect the cells
so why do we provide carbon dioxide well
i think everybody knows that
the reason we provide carbon dioxide in
an incubator is
to balance the ph
and so this is actually mimicking what's
going on
in the bloodstream so in this case uh
the pink kind of cloud represents my
sort of cartoon of the lobe of a lung
and the arrow represents a blood vessel
so
so the purple cells are blood cells that
are deprived of oxygen they're bringing
waste carbon dioxide which is a waste
by-product
of every cell in the body and so
they're actually less red as they're
carrying carbon dioxide instead of
oxygen
and it turns out that the oxygen
concentration in the lungs
where it's you know kind of full of
waste carbon dioxide produced by the
cell
is five percent co2 or 40 millimeters of
mercury
pressure and of course that's the most
common
co2 setting on the incubator is five
percent
so the incubator is mimicking what's
going on in the body
we also have oxygen in the lungs of
course
oxygen in the earth's atmosphere the air
we breathe is between
20 and 21 percent but in the lungs
the oxygen concentration is much lower
it's 14 percent
and this is because oxygen doesn't
diffuse very well
so of course what's happening in the
bloodstream in the lungs is that
waste metabolism waste co2 from the
cells is being expelled
into the lungs and you exhale it in your
breath and oxygen is coming in
now the other thing that's happening in
the bloodstream along with the co2
is there are natural bicarbonate ions
which serve as a natural buffer in the
bloodstream
and the bicarbonate ion concentration
is 24 millimolar which is equal to two
milligrams per milliliter sodium
bicarbonate which is the buffer most
commonly used
in cell culture growth media and the
same concentration
in eagle's minimal essential medium upon
which
most growth media are based so as you
can see the conditions we're providing
in the incubator
are there to mimic exactly what's going
on in the body
now we can look at it from my
biochemistry level but
in short the growth media include that
buffer the sodium bicarbonate
to work with the co2 and balance the ph
and it turns out that unlike oxygen
carbon dioxide gas
dissolves and diffuses really easily in
liquid so there's an equilibrium
with the gas phase or that provided by
the incubator
of the carbon dioxide and the carbon
dioxide in the growth medium
and so the sodium bicarbonate is there
to
give off and take up ions or you know to
balance and buffer that ph
now it turns out that fluctuations in
the carbon dioxide can affect the cell
morphology and growth and
i think most of us working in cell
culture are aware of this
but my point here is not just about the
incubator but also
when you're looking at yourselves under
the microscope take an extra minute or
two to look at that cell morphology
are the cell membranes nice and tight
against the dish if you're working with
adherent cells
do you see any any um
vacuoles in the in the cytoplasm that
might be an early indication of toxicity
for example
and that might be something to look at
for your carbon dioxide
so now let's think about how does
how do we control carbon dioxide in the
incubator
so there are a couple of different
sensor technologies an earlier
technology
is called thermal conductivity and
in this type of sensor the gas is not
directly
measured but it comes as a function of
the relative humidity and the
temperature and that's in accordance
with
oil's gas law that the pressure of the
gas will change
with other gases in the system including
water vapor and also with temperature
many of us are using infrared sensors
these are great for
connecting with monitoring systems for
example
infrared sensors were first introduced
in incubators in 1984
and an infrared sensor is essentially
like
a like a light bulb like a older
incandescent light bulb it has a
tungsten filament
that when electrified gives off light
um and so the gas enters the sensor
it interacts with the light all
wavelengths
except 4.3 micrometers at which
co2 gas absorbs light are
filtered out and then and then that that
amount of co2 gas
triggers an influx of carbon dioxide gas
as needed
now the thing about a tungsten infrared
bulb is
that that tungsten filament degrades
over time as it's heated
and so as a because of that the light
intensity decreases over time as well
when the light intensity decreases that
contributes to decreased
accuracy of the measurement and drift
of that measurement so one of the
options
is to get a newer technology where
instead of using tungsten
a silicon light source is used to
provide that
light and this turns out to be much more
stable
and much more long-lived than tungsten
bulbs it's kind of the equivalent of
moving from an
incandescent light bulb to an led light
bulb
and so so as i said a silicon light
source is much more stable
and long-lived than an older tungsten
style infrared light bulb
so how does this affect the recovery
after a door opening so just like with
temperature
we're going to look at how these
different technologies
affect the practical function of the
incubator
so in this graph we're looking at time
to recovery
to five percent carbon dioxide in
minutes
following a 30 second door opening of
these different incubators
and again these these charts these
measurements are based on
some of our internal testing but also
taken from brochures from different
manufacturers
so again going left to left to right
the silicon based ir sensor infrared
sensor
will recover from a 30-second door
opening in about four and a half minutes
a newer technology thermal conductivity
sensor which has
relative humidity compensation so that
that measurement is no longer dependent
on humidity
also recovers quite fast
the green bar indicates a bypass
infrared sensor which is a little bit
slower to recover and this makes sense
because
this sensor is outside the incubator
chamber and again we'll talk about that
a little bit later in the talk
if you have an incubator with an ir
sensor but it does not have a
circulating fan to speed recovery
you can see that doubles the recovery
time that's the out the yellow bar
and then finally if you have an older
style thermal conductivity sensor
and it's outside the incubator chamber
so it's a bypass sensor
i've actually had to truncate the graph
there so that recovery is 40 minutes
from a 30 second door opening so again i
hope i've demonstrated that different
technologies
can produce very different conditions
and of course that's going to affect
how your cells grow
so one final note on gas an atmosphere
in the incubator and that's
i wanted to point out that many of us
are also using
hypoxia in an incubator the point of
this
is to decrease the oxygen concentration
to mimic
what's going on in the human body so the
oxygen concentration in the earth's
atmosphere is between 20 and 21
so if you're listening to me from
melbourne australia it might be closer
to 21
because you're at sea level if you're in
basel in switzerland it might be a
little bit
less oxygen as you get higher altitude
so that would be closer to 20 percent
but in the earth in the in the human
body
as i mentioned earlier oxygen does not
diffuse very well
so the oxygen concentration in a given
tissue
will vary depending on how close those
cells in that tissue are
to oxygenated blood in the in the
circulatory system
so in solid tissues like the liver the
heart the kidneys
the oxygen concentration can be as low
as four percent
and in the eyes in the brain it's even
lower as you can see and
bone marrow where the stem cells grow
has very low oxygen
and so this is why we many of us
culture stem cells at hypoxia
so just keep in mind that a hypoxic
incubator uses nitrogen gas to decrease
the oxygen concentration in the
incubator and then you add in 5
co2 as usual and so that can affect the
function of the incubator and how your
cells grow also
so i'm not going to take much time to
talk about that now
just to let you know that that is
another function that we can look at
with regard to the incubator
okay so just like with temperature i
want to provide some tips
to you to maintain gas concentration in
whatever incubator you're using now
so the first of course is check your
carbon direct
check your carbon dioxide calibration at
least once a month using a secondary
probe or a fire right
system and check it early in the morning
first thing in the morning when you get
to the laboratory
before the incubator door has been open
and closed throughout the day as people
access their cultures if you're using a
hypoxic incubator
check the oxygen concentration first if
you want to do any calibrations
you want to manipulate the oxygen
setting
before then turning to the carbon
dioxide and that's because you're
reducing oxygen
but you're adding in carbon dioxide so
if you increase the co2 concentration
that can affect the oxygen measurement
use a gas guard an automatic tank
switcher so that if the
co2 tank runs out at night or on the
weekend
you don't run out of carbon dioxide and
again just like temperature
think about limiting the door openings
and the amount of time that the
incubator door is opened
if you're using hypoxia particularly you
might want to consider
degassing the media so using nitrogen to
bubble through
the growth media before applying it to
the cells
also if you're working with slow growing
cells like immune cells
or neural derived cells even if you
don't have to
split or passage the cells you might
want to consider changing to fresh media
every few days because as the cell
number in a given culture vessel
increases
so will the carbon dioxide because the
cells are giving off
carbon dioxide as their metabolism and
that can exhaust
the buffer in the growth media oh and
also use the correct carbon dioxide
setting for your media so
the carbon dioxide provided by the
incubator
depends on the buffering capability of
the growth media so
some growth media may require eight
percent
or ten percent carbon dioxide setting so
that's something to just check
okay so let's look at humidity this is
um the last parameter of the incubator
that i'm going to talk about
and it's one that's often overlooked so
let's talk about this
so the reason we provide humidity in the
co2 incubator is because
it reduces evaporation from the growth
media
so in very low humidity you get higher
evaporation
what happens when you get evaporation is
only
water leaves the culture media and as a
result
the remaining salts minerals hormones
nutrients etc become concentrated
and some of those factors
can reach toxic concentrations right so
the growth media that we use are
precisely balanced
for a reason and if the nutrients
or test factors you know things that
we're working with to stimulate the
cells become too concentrated
that can reach toxic concentration
so it also turns out that evaporation is
four times faster at 80 percent humidity
than at 93 percent humidity or greater
now so high humidity is a good thing but
as you approach 100
humidity then you get condensation
uh so it's essentially you know 100
humidity is
rain right so over about 95
humidity you can see condensation in the
incubator or
the water vapor collects and you see
puddles or droplets of water
so that's actually a bad thing like many
things in life it's a balance
because condensation can provide a
breeding ground for microbial
contamination
so you definitely want to have
proper humidity to prevent evaporation
from your
from your growth media or your cultures
um but also too much humidity can be bad
so
it's it's actually a very difficult
parameter to control well
humidity so let's let's look at how
humidity is controlled
in different systems and different
incubators just like temperature
humidity and carbon dioxide
humidity recovery from a 30 second door
opening depends on
design so this table is looking at time
to recover
to 90 percent humidity or greater
following a 30 second incubator door
opening
so again left to right the dark blue bar
shows humidity provided by a protected
or covered integrated water reservoir
so this is built into the floor of the
incubator
and the recovery there is less than 10
minutes that's very fast
humidity is very difficult to recover
fast
next to that the bar to the right the
other blue bar is
a similar built-in integrated water
reservoir
without a cover and you can see that
removing the cover slows
recovery a little bit and this makes
sense because as you keep things covered
they're going to dry out less so you get
higher humidity
the yellow bar is an external water
system
and what this is is it's an external
water reservoir
connected to a nebulizer that creates a
water vapor or mist
and that's injected directly to the
incubator chamber
and that's really fast to recover as
long as you have a circulating fan to
speed that recovery in that circulation
following a door opening and following
injection of the
atomized water and you can compare that
to the green bar to the right of that
yellow bar
which is a similar but different system
in an incubator without a circulating
fan
and then the last two bars the red and
the purple
just comparing surface area of a
traditional
standard water pan used to provide
passive humidity
in an incubator and so again i hope i've
demonstrated that different technologies
produce very different conditions even
though
a lot of incubators look very similar
from the outside it's the design and
engineering
that go into that incubator that can
produce very different conditions for
cells
so what can you do in your current
incubator to maintain proper humidity
the first thing is keep your water
reservoir full
more water equals higher humidity
but it's important to refresh that water
at least two times per month so that
your
um you get a chance to clean out the
water reservoir and eliminate any
microorganisms that may have colonized
that area
and then it's also important to use only
sterilized
distilled water because deionized or
ultra pure molecular grade water can
actually cause
corrosion in incubator just like with
temperature and carbon dioxide if you're
trying to maintain
an artificial environment inside the
incubator that's very different than the
conditions in the surrounding laboratory
limit the door openings and duration and
this is especially important
in a clean room where you may have the
ambient temperature in the laboratory
much lower than an incubator so normal
room temperature for many of us is
between 20 and 22 degrees celsius but in
a clean room if you're wearing a tyvek
suit of course
that gets very warm and so many clean
rooms are set at 16 degrees celsius
and they're drier than the incubator or
even then a typical laboratory which is
about 50
humidity so that's that increases the
difference between
the ambient laboratory and the incubator
when you're in a clean room
also consider using larger culture
volumes and i assume that many of you
are
scaling up your culture vessels and so
of course that
also helps prevent evaporation just
because
you'll well any evaporation that does
occur will be less
dramatic because it'll be you know
dispersed
through a larger volume ensure proper
airflow make sure that your incubator
has a circulating fan
in the incubator chamber and then that
fan is properly cleaned and properly
operating
and then finally um if you're using
small volumes if you're using 96 well or
384 well plates these really small
volumes
are more susceptible to evaporation
and so one one option there is to use
this kind of unique
um the nunc edge multi-well plates where
there's a moat
surrounding the microwells that you can
fill with distilled water to
help kind of cushion that evaporation
and reduce evaporation from the
wells inside in the center of the plate
and it also reduces edge effect quite
quite a lot so that's
humidity we've also talked about
temperature
and carbon dioxide gas so
i just want to now kind of pull it all
together
and show you that all of these
parameters work together for cell
health so i know this is a little bit
hard to read but these are just um
just to remind you of each of those
graphs that i presented individually for
temperature
carbon dioxide and humidity but a lot of
times we don't talk about humidity for
example and we think more about
temperature than co2 but
i just wanted to emphasize that all of
these parameters work together for cell
health
and of course it's critical for cells to
spend maximal time at ideal conditions
because
as those conditions change that can
affect how the cells react
and then finally i hope these graphs
demonstrate that different technologies
yield very different results
so i mentioned with regard to each of
those
parameters temperatures carbon dioxide
and humidity
i mentioned a temp a probe that's in a
in a bypass loop so i wanted to
talk about that a little bit more and
describe what do i mean by that
so this slide shows
my drawing of what a bypass loop might
look like it's sort of electronics
for biologists if you will so what
happens here
is um you can see that there's an arrow
that
forms a u-turn and that represents
tubing coming to and from the incubator
chamber
okay so we're essentially in a box
inside the
incubator housing but outside the
incubator chamber
and so this tubing removes an air sample
from the incubator chamber where the
cells are
passes through a filter to restrict any
airborne contaminants
passes through a pump to keep the air
moving and then
encounters the sensor which then reacts
to that air sample
now because this is outside the
incubator chamber
we also have to have a separate heater
so this compartment is also heated
to the same temperatures the incubator
chambers 37 degrees
but it's a completely separate heater
and it's not something
that you're going to calibrate if you
check the temperature on your incubator
you just don't have access to that so my
point here is that
a bypass sensor simply does not
um react to the same conditions that
your cells are in in the incubator
chamber it just can't
so why why would we why would somebody
offer this in an incubator
and i guess the thing is that if you
think about what's going on in the
incubator chamber from a cell's
perspective not only or from an
electronics perspective i guess is
better
not only is that incubator chamber
heated to 37 degrees
and not only is it very humid and of
course both of those things are very
hard on electronics
but the co2 gas is providing an
atmosphere
that is weakly acidic due to carbonic
acid
and so that's very detrimental to
electronics
so if you put the sensor outside
of that carbon dioxide gas and outside
of that high humidity
it helps preserve the life of the sensor
so
in other words inside the incubator
chamber you need
very solid state very robust components
to withstand those conditions but the
important thing is
that if you're using a sensor to react
and to control the conditions that the
cells are experiencing
then you want to have the sensor react
or experience the same conditions that
the cells are experiencing and
that just can't happen with a bypass
sensor
so look for an incubator with sensors in
the incubator chamber that are going to
experience
the same conditions as your cells don't
require
additional equipment in an external
space
this allows those sensors and probes to
constantly sample
and react the conditions in the in the
incubator chamber
to react to the same conditions as
yourself and that will give you faster
recovery
after a door opening
okay now i just want to finish up
talking about uniformity
so another thing that you want to think
about with regard to an incubator
for cell therapy especially as you're
getting to larger sized incubators and
larger culture vessels
is that you want the cells regardless of
where they are in the incubator to react
to the same conditions because the cells
reacted changes in temperature and ph
and and the concentration of nutrients
in the medium
so you want the incubator to give you
the same conditions
regardless of where you look at in the
incubator chamber so uniformity
throughout the chamber from top to
bottom
is important and
if i look at this a little bit closer
if you think just about temperature um
air hot air rises right so if you stay
in one of those fancy hotels
with with a big atrium that's maybe 14
stories high
and you get off the elevator on the 14th
floor and the
the whole space is opened all the way
down to the first floor
the ground floor you find that the
temperature is much warmer
on the 14th floor in that atrium than it
is on the first floor so
we know that heat rises but that's not
all
it turns out that carbon dioxide gas is
heavier than air
so it sinks and nitrogen
gas used in a hypoxic incubator to
decrease the oxygen concentration
that nitrogen gas is lighter than air so
it rises
so without a circulating fan you can
have stratification of conditions
inside an incubator
such that cells at the top will
experience very different conditions
themselves at the bottom and if you're
doing
a large production or a large experiment
if you're an r d um you will have cells
in different conditions depending on
where your culture vessel is in the
incubator chamber
so the only way to ensure that you have
uniformity throughout the chamber
is to use a circulating fan
now we've talked about how a circulating
fan provides fast recovery and i
demonstrated that
with the with the table showing
different engineering designs
we just talked about how a circulating
fan provides uniform conditions
sometimes you will hear that a
circulating fan is bad
because it dries out yourself and that
again depends on the engineering
and design if the fan is flowing super
fast and
blowing directly onto your cell cultures
i
yes i can imagine it would be possible
to see desiccation of your growth media
and drying out of your cells but if you
have gentle airflow circulation if it's
designed to circulate quickly
but you know not to blow directly on
culture so that as this
image shows you get turbulent gentle
airflow then you don't see desiccation
you don't see evaporation from the
growth media
and a circulating fan provides two
additional benefits as well
you can provide hepa filtration to
capture airborne microorganisms that
might be coming in
from the laboratory from the humans
working in the laboratory
and a circulating fan reduces
condensation
in the incubator chamber so condensation
that would lead to microbial
contamination
for example so again
some final tips to maintain uniformity
and recovery
in in your incubator that you currently
have
um number one of course look for an
incubator with a circulating fan
number two look for data provided by the
manufacturer on recovery
don't just look at specifications so if
you're comparing incubators
everybody has a list of specifications
that they meet
so temperature variability for example
but
it's also important to look at data
demonstrating
how those specifications look so i've
got two examples here
on the left is a chart showing recovery
of humidity following a 30 second door
opening and on the right is the
temperature map
showing a 27 point temperature map
throughout the incubator chamber
also calibrating of course monthly will
maintain your uniformity and your
recovery
as i said earlier keep the water pan
full or the water reservoir
and as always i'm trying to reduce the
length
and the number of the door openings
so let's talk about some conclusions um
just as a review the points i want you
to remember from my talk today
all incubator parameters affect cell
growth it's not just about temperature
it's not just about ph or co2 but also
humidity plays a big role
in how your cells grow and so as i hope
i've shown you
the design and quality that goes into
the incubator affect the function the
location of the sensors
affects how they perform such that
in-chamber sensors will experience the
same conditions as your cells
a bypass sensor which is outside the
incubator chamber
simply experiences different conditions
than yourself
experiencing and that different designs
can provide different results in your
process or your cell growth
so unit recovery after a door opening
and uniformly throughout the incubator
chamber
again affect the cell growth and so air
circulation
with a circulating fan is required for
uniformity and fast recovery
and you can ask for these data from the
manufacturers if you think about
if you're looking at for example um
initiating a new institute a new
building you're expanding your processes
and you're thinking about a large
incubator
purchase don't just look at
specifications a list of specifications
but ask for these data
and even consider buying a single
incubator from a few different
manufacturers to compare
how that incubator performs in your
processes
because your end product depends on the
cell health and the cell health is
dependent on the co2 incubator
okay so just to finish up a few words
about the nice people who sent me here
thermoscientific has been making co2
incubators for more than 50 years
and so that provides us with proven
technology
and engineering and performance
leadership many of the innovations
available on co2 incubators today
were invented by our engineering team
also we provide factory trained
technical support
and service teams so these people go to
the
factory they turn the screws and they're
trained
on how these incubators work from the
ground up
and they're available to help you in
person or by telephone
and they know the incubators inside out
also because of our history
we work closely with cell culturists and
cell therapy institutes around the world
to try and keep up with the changing
needs
as we go forward in the 21st century and
cell and gene therapy
becomes more and more applied we also
have a lot of different choices
so that we can match your incubator to
your needs and that includes everything
on this list but also
we can provide customizations as needed
if you have specific design requirements
for example you want an incubator that's
built into the wall of your clean room
instead of being wholly
included inside the clean room those are
things we can work with you
and then contamination control hepa
filtration
proven high temperature sterilization
that meets the standards
provided by the united states and
european pharmacopoeias for example
and then we have newer technologies that
have been invented in the last few years
including even better gentle airflow
circulation in our newer
models newer sensor
technologies i talked about that a
little bit
the water reservoir giving super fast
humidity recovery
and so on we also i mentioned our
factory trained service teams
we can provide documents and we can
provide specialists who will come to
your site
to help you with iq oq and temperature
mapping
and i mentioned customization so
one new thing that we have that is
really designed for separating projects
and if you're a company that's working
on
a vaccine for covid19 for example and
you're
designing different viral vectors
for vaccine production is just one
example you might consider our cell
locker system and this is a unique
design
that includes six autoclavable
polycarbonate chambers
that segregate the inside of the
incubator chamber into six
individual compartments they have
membrane filters that allow air
circulation for human uniformity but
restrict circulation of microorganisms
and so when you open one of these
chamber doors the other five do not
experience
that door opening so for example if
you're working with stem cells
they remain at their ideal conditions um
much more uniformly than if you were to
open the entire incubator door and
microorganisms as i said are restricted
so that's all i have today there's more
information there's a lot of technical
information
at our website at thermofisher.com and
susie i'm ready to take any questions
wow thank you mary kay for that
presentation
and we will now start the live q a
session
of this webinar and a quick reminder to
our audience
on how to submit questions simply type
them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window
labeled ask a question and click that
send button
mary kay will answer as many questions
as time permits today
and we have quite a few questions coming
in already mary kay
let me start with the first one how do
you verify
that your temperature is correct on the
led
readout of your incubator and there's a
part two
can you use a thermometer placed
into the incubator
um so it sounds like you answered your
own question with the second question so
yes the way that you would verify the
temperature
on the led readout of the of the
incubator
is there could be lcd2 by the way
is you use a secondary temperature probe
and you want to use one
uh if you're in the united states that's
nist certified
so the national institutes of standards
and
what the t stands for might be
temperature
so you want a calibrated secondary
thermometer and even those can vary by
0.1 to 0.2 to up to 1 degree so make
sure you
use a temperature the secondary
temperature probe that you know the
calibration
on so that you know if you're if your
incubator
says that 37 degrees and your secondary
temperature probe says
38 degrees it doesn't mean the incubator
is wrong so you
you need to use a secondary temperature
probe that you know has been calibrated
and you know what
the difference the plus or minus
variation on that
secondary temperature probe might be but
yes so the idea is use
secondary temperature sensor and put
that in the incubator chamber
wonderful thank you and when cells are
taken out of an incubator
say for observation under a microscope
the media temperature cools down towards
ambient
temperature of the room how does this
drop in temperature
affect the ph of the media and that's
the cells
wow okay so you're absolutely right that
that temperature can affect
the co2 it should not affect the k
buffering capability of the sodium
bicarbonate or the hepes or whatever
buffer is in your growth media
so the temperature should not affect the
buffering capability of the co2 because
the idea of a buffer
is that it's going to take up and give
off hydrogen ions
to balance that ph and certainly that's
not going to change in a short term
thank you for that and i again want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
coming in our next question how are
vacuoles
um related to toxicity
or toxicity i'm sorry how are the how
are back
how are vacuoles related to toxic
um toxicity toxic i apologize
that's a fun girl
related to toxicity and and that is my
fault i
misspoke i actually meant to say
granules in the cytoplasm
when talking about carbon dioxide and ph
not vacuoles
so thank you for calling me out on that
so i could clarify that
granules can be an indicator of toxicity
not vacuoles
perfect and what is the ideal
maintenance temperature of the growth
medium
so i'm not exactly sure what you mean by
that but
ideally of course you would store media
[Music]
for up to a month or so in at four
degrees celsius
not at 37 degrees so i hope that answers
your question
and mary kay do you recommend co2
measuring devices
i don't have one specifically that i
would recommend
certainly thermal scientific does have a
secondary
co2 ir sensor we can provide
there are some from other manufacturers
too and many people use
a handheld firewrite device just make
sure that
um you know just as i was talking about
older style
infrared sensors can drift over time if
you're using a secondary
ir co2 probe or even oxygen probe you
want to make sure that that's been
calibrated in the last year also
thank you and our next audience member
asks
says we currently do a manual decon
process
every six months but are looking at more
of an automated
with h2o2 decontamination or heat
decontamination what are your
recommendations
on routine incubator decontamination
so my first recommendation
is to look at the proof of efficacy
okay so hydrogen peroxide is a really
great disinfectant
it's broad spectrum it will kill pretty
much anything
um including the thyroscopic two virus
um but it's it's a little bit difficult
to automate
so there's a lot of handling involved
and um
the problem with an automated system for
hydrogen peroxide is
that there are areas that maybe will be
shadowed
from the mist and if that
if those droplets miss an area of
of the incubator chamber then any
microorganisms there would obviously
survive because they wouldn't be
contacted
by that hydrogen peroxide disinfectant
um so look for proof of efficacy
according to
the united states and european
pharmacopoeias or the pharmacopoeia
relevant for urination
there they've gotten pretty harmonized
in that
instead of for example for heat
sterilization
they used to recommend a given
temperature and time so 160 degrees for
two hours and that would constitute
sterilization
sterilization but it's now recognized
that if you don't reach that given
temperature
um microorganisms may survive because
they're not actually at 160 degrees for
two hours for example
so now the pharmacopoeias recommend or
require
proof of sterilization using one million
organisms resistant bacterial spores
which are proven
to have a specific devalue
and i won't go into what that all means
right now but my point is that
sterilization is now defined as
elimination of one million resistant
microorganisms and those microorganisms
are specified
biological indicators so look for a
process
that has been independently tested
to verify that it meets that
sterilization requirement
and there are companies that will come
in and do a
manual chemical disinfectant
on your incubator and many of those are
good
make sure that it won't corrode or cause
degradation of the electronics in your
incubator
and make sure that that company is going
to verify neutralization of the chemical
that they use
and document the efficacy in the end
that they truly did sterilize your
system
thank you for that and again audience
members great questions we have time for
a few more questions
mary clay do you have any
recommendations for how
often one should change co2 sensors
and in parentheses um she writes
hair cell bios incubators
okay um well uh full disclosure the hair
cell bios is my favorite incubator
um so the sensor and how often you have
to replace it depends on the sensor
itself
so for example thermal conductivity
sensor
is very stable and will last the life of
the incubator generally
um the newer infrared sensors
so if you have a hair cell bios it has
that silicon based
infrared sensor i mentioned and that is
going to have a very long service life
generally the service life for a piece
of laboratory equipment is expected to
be seven to ten years
and so my recommendation is if you have
an older style infrared sensor
and you start to see drift over the
carbon dioxide measurement
it's probably time to replace that
sensor
so i guess the short answer is older
infrared sensors
are expected to last maybe five years
thermal conductivity sensors should last
the life of your incubator especially if
you're
keeping the calibration and the humidity
constant
and then the silicon-based infrared
sensors should
approach the life of your incubator
lifetime
thank you for that and here's our next
question
it's two parts what kind of device do
you recommend to use to measure
co2 level and if the co2 level
was wrong is it easy to modify co2
levels
by ourselves um
depending on the incubator there are
should be instructions
in the user manual for modifying the
calibration or
basically what's you know the offset of
the co2 sensor
for replacement of the sensor i would
recommend a factory trained service
specialist
and i hope i answered the question if i
if i didn't quite answer that correctly
let me know ricky
how do you control variable oxygen
concentrations
if growing a variety of cells at a
particular time
in the incubator so
in order to so an incubator has one
oxygen
sensor generally if you're going to use
different oxygen concentrations you
would need multiple
oxygen sensors um so a single incubator
can control
oxygen to one particular setting whether
that's one percent oxygen or five
percent
so on um we do offer a small modular
chamber that
holds um holds 12
i think it's 12 petri dishes and nine
multi-well plates
i might have those numbers a little bit
off and that can be placed inside any
incubator you
to control oxygen so you can test
with multiple of these small chambers
you could test different oxygen
concentrations
the thing to know about that is that it
does require some external equipment
in order to provide that oxygen so you
need a
canister of pre-mixed gas with the
concentrations of gas that you're
interested
in testing you need a pump you need
tubing and you need a regulator
but once you get all that set up you
you just put your cell vessels in the
chamber you charge the chamber with gas
and then put it in the incubator and
it's a good way
to test multiple oxygen concentrations
simultaneously
thank you mary kay we have time for one
more question hopefully you can help
this audience remember
she says in my lab since few days uh
since a few days of amniotic cells do
not grow
after the first initiation but after
first media transfer to second t25 flask
the
cells start to grow and the growth after
next media
addition is very unpredictable what's
going on
what's wrong with this so
i haven't grown amniotic cells myself
but the oxygen concentration in the
uterus
is very low usually
between two and five percent oxygen
and when you have primary cells such as
cells i'm assuming these are primary
cells um
yeah they're they're kind of maybe in
shock you could say
um even if you're simulating the oxygen
concentration in the uterus
um so if
if you're not stimulating the oxygen
concentration then that can
play a role here so for most primary
cells i would recommend
a hypoxic incubator um
so if you look at a graph of primary
cell growth
in an incubator that is controlling
oxygen to simulate the in vivo
conditions and one that's not
in the one that's not you might see the
cells grow for a day or two when first
removed from the body
and then as you describe you'll see a
lag
where they'll just they won't
necessarily die but they'll just kind of
be in
in stasis for a little while they're
cellular couch potatoes
and then after you know several more
days you might
see the growth curve start to go up
where they're actually starting to
multiply
what's happening during that lag is that
the cells are actually mutating
genetically to adjust to those
artificial conditions
so i would encourage you to look at
hypoxia and do some research in the
primary literature to see how other
people
are incubating those cells and what
conditions they're
using because that can play a big role
in how primary cells grow especially if
you're looking for them
to mimic conditions in the body you want
them to be
genetically similar to you know the way
they were in the body before you put
them in culture
so i hope that helps well thank you very
much mary kay
and thank you for this great
presentation today do you have any
closing
remarks for our audience before we close
today
um i guess i would just say um to
re-emphasize
um a lot of the information that i
presented today was
unknown to me when i worked in the lab i
kind of assumed that
an incubator is very similar to another
incubator and i hope i've demonstrated
that in
practice that's actually not true and
that that can have effects on your cells
so if you're thinking about a new
incubator purchase especially if you're
in a
cellular gene therapy company
and you're thinking about a large
purchase one thing to do
is to consider buying a single unit for
you to test
to run through the iqoq qualifications
that you might be looking at because
that's going to affect your processes in
the long run
and that's it thanks everybody for
attending i really appreciate it and
thanks again to susie and everyone at
lab roots for a great
format thank you for your important
research before we go
i want to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions and as a reminder any
questions
that weren't answered today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
i'd also like to thank labrus and our
sponsor thermofish
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share this email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
stay safe be healthy and have a great
day bye